hello winner how are you feeling
oh i'm just i just can't come down from
this like i don't know if i
ever will i was just joking on my social
media everyone's like where are you
gonna put the mirror ball and i'm like
depends what room i'm in i'll take it
everywhere with me i'm gonna put that
thing
is it in the bed with you at this point
you must just be like laying with it
i usually i didn't actually bring it
into the room last night right now it's
right here
in my office behind me yeah so wherever
i am
it will be caitlyn and arnold
[Applause]
okay what went through your mind when
they called your name
honestly a little bit of disbelief
because i truly thought knee was gonna
win
and while i was standing there and i'm
that pause that tyra did was the longest
pause in tv history
and so when i heard her say caitlyn and
artem i just
honestly like my it felt out of body
like i felt like i had an out of body
experience
and i just like i watch it back and i'm
dying because i
i forgot i was mite and i was screaming
and like
like not a cute like it was like
like screaming so happy it was just pure
joy
oh my god i can't even hear you they're
so excited
you went through so much i mean from
injuries to trolls you know respecting
to carry on and ava
went through a lot i was not super
impressed you need to give us more
so what does it mean to win at this
point like it means so much more
when you can look back on your three
months there and be like
i was grinding i was in that studio
every day seven days a week no days off
six hours a day
we like walked in and it wasn't like we
didn't take a lunch break we were
in it to win it and coming back from
like an ankle injury thinking i wasn't
gonna dance like everything just makes
it that much sweeter this has been just
the most
incredible life-changing journey for me
i heard that jason said
he wouldn't propose if you didn't win i
know he was joking
is the pressure on now you know
christmas is coming we got a mirror ball
i'm not really the kind of person that's
like put a ring on it i
joke about that but i'm like whenever
you're ready like whenever we're ready
whenever the time is right i just
i want to be surprised it could happen
tonight it could happen in like next
year it could happen i don't
know i don't know no rush we know it'll
happen
and it again could happen tonight who
knows imagine